young man had respect for I guess take
the ladies outside and show where we
keep the freezers keys and genders bear
with us for two minutes but she's gonna
show something I'd like you to see yes
so just follow me this just right down
here
watch her yes right here back to the
trash yes this is our lasagna this is
our trout we got more sausage ice cream
these are your april for a day yes yes
ma'am
yes ma'am we've got two freezers and
everything scattered very cluttered
I mean Karen has always but did this ass
her home obviously it is embarrassing
but it's a serious situation I needs to
be solved
okay I'm sorry my apologies I discovered
that today and I had respect for you as
customers I can't sit here and fake you
eating that [ __ ] so I'm hoping that you
can skip around the menu and order
something a little bit more thank you
keeping my apologies thank you thank you
do you have purple glasses earlier yeah
yeah oh that is so cool because they
look like they're dark brown or black oh
that is so cool this is insane
yeah Sarah claims to work at the
Townsend here's a free postcard for
everybody when I go to serve tables she
randomly show up we'll talk to tables
I've seen her frustrate people sir
they don't need to hear your life story
they want to sit and have a romantic
drink on the terrace
leave them alone there are other tables
okay we're gonna need a rotisserie
chicken that's the rotisserie chicken
you get it from the freezer yeah
disgusting just playing the rotisserie
chicken please show the table yeah this
is the dish of the day it's our
rotisserie chicken
it was roasted six months ago in a
grocery store and we're serving it for
$12 all the menus got rotisserie chicken
yeah buy them at a grocery store yes and
you freeze them and you reheat them in
the microwave not in the microwave okay
one in the microwave what is going on
here well we have a menu any we just do
it I know it's pathetic how many of your
guests tonight think that their chickens
be roasted in the house maybe yes let's
just let me come in Anderson let's
double check
ladies and gentlemen so sorry I can't
have your attention 30 seconds how many
of you were going to order the roast
chicken this evening would expect it to
be fresh roasted in-house for you raise
your hands please I think everybody
a lot of people say it's it's good I
agree these guys have come out of their
homes to come and eat or I'm not going
to do is attempt to pull the wool over
their eyes because they deserve to know
what's going on with those were cooked
yesterday he reheated in a pan boiling
them in water and I'm flabbergasted so
you need to take a real good look at
yourself and stop bullshitting customers
immediately otherwise I'm out of here
I'm so sorry but you as customers
deserve better
and there's nothing to do with a TV
program I promise you now is based on
the bad practices that's going on in
that kitchen so my apologies but I'm not
allowed to eat you're not responsible
for it I will we're shutting it down